si vous aimez bien jean-michel ou pas
euh oui bien sûr sophie davant est avec
moi pas du soir dans ça
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mais c'est pas la patronne senti pour
moi c'est la taulière de la télé ça
rester la patronne ya michel drucker et
sophie davant moi quand j'ai beaucoup
d'amis et de fans oui qu'ils sont fous
de sophie ils sont voilà qui son délire
sur sophie quoi ils ont vite ils sont
vides à pécho était sur un bail quoi
franchement moi tubes mais présentent
jamais ses joies on va s'occuper de toi
que tu va repartir
moi j'étais pour vol avec l'inde est à
mon avis sera pas possible démission ya
maintenant quelques dizaines de mois
dans une case qui était à 5 %
voilà aujourd'hui maintenant elle à 20%
est vraie elle a fait 4 fois le sport de
cette casse est absolument
extraordinaire
1981 1983 première génération minitel
effectivement vous en attendez entre
5000 et 10000 euros non c'est non je
pense mais je pense alors si jamais
blanc que j'aime bien ce côté gentleman
chardon
c'est là le pantalon en velours côtelé
non là bas il a juste merci d'hackney je
trouve ça sympa c'est moi qui la réponse
téléphone suivant dispute on discute sur
pour l'avenir et bon moi j'ai déplacé on
en espère qu'ils se verront le jour
merci sophy sava sophie et me regarder
au delà vous voyez un ouf
[Rires]
mais vous êtes une romantique ça vous
surprend
non pas du tout alors mais c'est vrai
bon us open et romantique quoi donc
énorme antique ses meilleurs et vous
vous êtes lourdingue là-bas chromatique
ce que vous aimez bien jean-michel ou
pas oui j'aime bien le côté poivre et
sel et les barbus de trois jours ah oui
et j'avoue quand même qu'il est pas mal
non ça dépend pour quoi en fait
c'est à dire pour une nuit bertreau pour
une vie jean michel horn allons
peut-être pas jusque là mais on aime
activité très bien mais choquée elle est
bien jean-michel un sofitel demander
longtemps soupçonné s'offrir fois est-ce
que vous accepteriez un dîner avec jean
michel maire vous allez revenir à ce
qu'elle avait passé la dernière fois
c'est pour moi c'est cadeau c'est moi
qui régale à choisir du hippopotamus
[Rires]
[Musique]